today's Thursday April 24th welcome to
gamespot news Chris waters here to carry
the news torch that Jess McDonald left
lying around the newsroom yesterday home
setting all of our news on fire I
managed to save most of the stuff and
though they're a little charred I can
read all of them except for this one
which says something about Alf life
three I don't even know they made an Alf
life one on with the news the past and
present gears of war developers both
made some headlines today with a bunch
of highfalutin nonspecific talk about
the games they're working on
dualshockers calm spotted a bunch of new
job listings at black tusk studios the
devs who are working on a new gears of
war for the Xbox one the listings for
artists engineers and level designers
include such delicious hyperbole as
industry-leading multiplayer experience
innovative features and leading-edge new
rendering techniques to deliver the best
in class visuals for a triple a console
game meanwhile Gears of War creators
Epic Games teased a mysterious new
project of their own telling edge that
it's going to push next-generation
graphics as you'd always expect epic to
do epics game is apparently in
pre-production and not expected to be
formally announced anytime soon but with
e3 less than two months away the time
for big announcements is coming up soon
I hope in more concrete news featuring
things you can actually see and soon
play titanfall developer Respawn
Entertainment has released images of the
first map from its upcoming DLC the map
featured is called wargames a virtual
reality world described as a quote park
or playground which features elements
from other maps including angel city
rise and air base Sierra this wall
runner friendly Frank and map will be
bundled along with two other maps
swampland and run off in the expedition
DLC which will be downloadable for about
ten bucks sometime in the future you can
also get it as part of the season pass
for titanfall which will run you about
twenty-five dollars in the nearer more
concrete exactly one week away future a
new slate of free games are coming to
PlayStation Plus subscribers
puppeteer leads the ps3 pack with
Skullgirls encore and payday 2 free only
in the US and Europe respectively
American Vita owners can tangle with the
starkly beautiful limbo while European
Vita owners wrangle the ornately
gorgeous Muramasa rebirth the
PlayStation 4 will receive only the
brainy comedic platformer stick it to
the man arriving early in the month in
the US and later in Europe for the full
list check out the new story on gamespot
I've actually been meaning to play stick
it to the man after GameSpot gave it a 7
out of 10 and one commenter said the art
style reminded them of a 2d psychonauts
because psychonauts is friggin awesome
let's round things out with a few quick
headlines just to give you all a taste
of what else is going on in the wide
world of gaming one devout Resident Evil
fan has produced a proof of concept
video showing a remastered version of
Resident Evil 2 that feels a lot like
Resident Evil 4 mario kart 8 Wii U
bundles that include a 32 gigabyte
system a racing wheel gamepad protector
mario or luigi hat wii remote plus and a
mario kart 8 game guide have been
announced for the UK but no word yet on
a US release and finally market research
company eed are revealed that according
to their research the number of gamers
in china surpasses the total number of
citizens in the United States but with a
14-year ban on consoles just lifted
earlier this year and strict government
censorship rules in place how exactly
the Chinese gaming market will evolve in
the coming years is still uncertain
that's all for today be sure to visit
gamespot com / news for up-to-the-minute
stories as they break I'll be back
tomorrow with our top 5 stories of the
week see you then